so Helen Jim is learning to live again
step by fraile step his virus ravaged
body is weak he's woken up after a month
in a coma asleep that saved his life I
had a visit from the itu surgeon who
basically said you came up with with the
whole team and said we need to put you
into induced sleep I was so ill by that
time I was just like fine you know like
do what you have to do I've known Sahel
for over 20 years
still I struggle to recognize the man
sitting in front of me it was only when
I woke up it was only then I came to
realize that you know I had been you
know in a coma for almost a month
Sahel was put on a ventilator but the
odds of surviving Coheed 19 in an ICU
are not good it was 5050 right I mean
after I kind of woke up they told me you
like it was touch-and-go it could have
gone either way
what the hell didn't know was that his
mother Rashida Begum was admitted to the
same hospital just a few days after he
was and as he lay in a deep coma she was
just a few wards away dying of Kovac 19
she went into hospital think on Monday
and passed away like two days later and
I came to learn over death a month later
after I woke up Rashida Begum continued
to pray for her son's recovery until her
last breath you know I believe that you
know like she was basically praying
for my health that was her prayers
helped you yeah basically I believe that
it was you know her prayers you know to
God you know to make me well again sahel
saw patients dying around him and he
knows too that he would have also died
had it not been for the skill of the
doctors and nurses who saved him
if the doctors hadn't put me into an
induced coma at the time it may have
been a different story for me so I may
not have been sitting here today sahel
will spend the next six months
rebuilding his shattered body but like
thousands of other survivors he has no
idea what long-term damage the virus has
done to him but he does know Coe bid 19
is a life taking and life-changing
disease fascist Joshi Skyy names